welcome back we usually have our morning
cup of joe segment with sheriff joe
lombardo on wednesdays as you see there
that is not sheriff joe lombardo he's
running for governor so we have mornings
with metro we're joined live now by
assistant sheriff brett zimmerman
assistant sheriff good to see you sir
hey good morning thank you for having me
of course
so the fourth of july is coming up it is
on sunday every year we get complaints
you get complaints about illegal
fireworks and fires
a lot of our viewers say nothing gets
done what can we expect from
law enforcement on this independence day
well we over the years we started a
campaign
called you light it we write it it's
targeted to illegal fireworks
we encourage the public who is
celebrating the fourth of july
within the law to purchase fireworks at
those stands you see
and have a good time on the fourth of
july with the ones that are legal
but the illegal ones are the ones we're
concerned about
last year we had probably eleven
thousand calls for service
on the fourth of july seven thousand of
them were firework related
uh what we usually do for enforcement is
we will
team our officers up with our task force
it's made up of
also henderson north las vegas some
other jurisdictions that assist with us
and and our and our partners over at the
fire department
and we will go out and uh and enforce
the illegal fireworks ordinances and uh
we encourage people to go to
uh the website which is i spy firework
www.icepyfireworks.com
to report that illegal activity we
monitor that
constantly and it's a lot quicker than
calling 311
to get your fireworks complaint handled
assistant sheriff we've been tracking
the spike as i'm sure metro has the
spike in car thefts across the valley
we've discussed it previously here on
good day what is the latest on trying to
enforce and cut
we've got a 26 increase on auto theft
year to date
uh you know some of it is is pandemic
related last year
a lot of people were home and weren't
driving and weren't out and what we're
still seeing this year is
people leaving their cars running
running into a convenience store or
parked in front of their home
and someone it's there it's their the
opportunities there to steal the vehicle
and we we currently put together an auto
theft task force that involves every
area command
and north las vegas and henderson and
each area of command is coming to the
table
with their problem areas with the areas
not only where cars are being stolen
but also where cars are being recovered
because that's a good place to start in
arresting people because if we know cars
are being
dumped after they're stolen in a
specific area being stripped there
those are areas to also take a look at
it we're seeing certainly a lot more
people on the las vegas strip now the
resort corridor downtown as well
that more people means more need for law
enforcement to some extent and there's a
the bike patrol program on the las vegas
strip
let's talk a little bit about what it
does and how
successful or just how it has
accomplished things to try and keep
crime down on the strip uh
just this past january we basically
converted as many officers that we could
at our convention center area command
over to bikes and bikes are more visible
bikes can get through traffic a lot
easier
in regards to you know intersections
where traffic's backed up
bikes can go up the alleys where
criminal activity is being
committed and what we've seen in the
last uh in the last few months
is that our productivity and our
enforcement on the strip
has basically doubled in regards to the
conversion of bikes
assistant sheriff brett zimmerman thank
you very much for joining us this
morning
if you at home have a question for metro
police you can of course submit it at
eightnewsnow.com
find out if your question is answered
every wednesday